a normal candidate flips pancakes I
guess you probably flip the pancake in
your life yes I have not so normal a
squadron of Secret Service agents
watches her every move this is normal
walking out at a wonky policy forum on
early childhood development you know the
famous word gap study which is a kind of
snapshot study of you know people who
are better stimulated talk to on all of
that who then you know have heard 30
million more words than a kid from a
less advantaged background Clinton's
communications director Jennifer
Palmieri says her candidate is in fact
pretty much normal the elements are all
their cafe like a normal person a lot of
contact with voters a lot of one-on-one
time with voters big town halls you see
here answering a lot of questions she
loves all that a lot of interviews as
well a lot of local and national here's
another thing a typical candidate does
Clinton huddled with her staff to come
up with a soundbite to make sure her gun
message got on the news what's the most
obvious way to do that mention a certain
Republican frontrunner mr. trump was
asked about it and said something like
you know things like that happen in the
world and governor Bush said yeah stuff
happens know that that's a that's an
admission of defeat and surrender to a
problem that is killing 33,000 Americans
but the size of her entourage and the
unusually controlled formality of
Clinton's interactions with voters makes
her seem less like a challenger and more
like a defending champ it's huge America
towards perfection that she has is very
cautious staff that when she'd on the
worldwide she's not answering reporter
and she's just sticking on message and
and that's really different from the way
that a lot of other candidates work
here's another example of how Clinton is
an unusual candidate a reporter she's
known for almost a quarter century
standing inches away from her asked her
questions and she pretends she can't
hear him then what's your message what's
your message to the NRA secretary is
your question about guns Secretary
Clinton are you Kirkland what's your
message the NRA but like a normal
candidate clinton will take questions
from a New Hampshire voter on another
rope line even if it's the same question
that the reporter asked for the NRA not
even talking about it yeah I you know
just gave up I just stood up the Town
Hall about that you know
my message is not to them or for them my
message is the American people it is
time that we stood up together for
common sense gun safety measures to end
the epidemic of gun violence and that is
going to be an issue that I emphasized
in the campaign and that i'm going to
work as hard as i can to get something
done in Washington but it has to come
from the bottom up hmm that voter asks
the exact same question as the reporter
coincidence I don't think so I tried to
ask Hillary Clinton message was the NRA
she wouldn't answer me so what I do I
went to the middle lady what you do I
asked her the question how'd it work out
it was great she gave me a great answer
and she interacted with me and she gave
me an answer that I value and I think it
made sense you won I won and Hillary
Clinton won it was perfect